[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und bettina schausten
guten abend in china hat der freitag
bereits begonnen und damit der tag der
eröffnung der olympischen winterspiele
die chinesische führung hat das land
abgeschottet in der pandemie nun lädt
sie die jugend der welt in eine olympia
blase ein zusammen passen tut das nicht
sechs deutsche athleten unter anderem
aus dem eishockey team wurden heute
positiv getestet und über allen hängt
corona wie ein damoklesschwert
negativ und als fahnenträger nominiert
sind diese beiden die eisschnellläuferin
claudia pechstein zum achten mal dabei
und der bobfahrer francesco friederich
werden das deutsche team anführen beim
einzug ins olympiastadion eine große
ehre sagen beide das sogenannte
vogelnest ist nun nach den sommerspielen
2008 zum zweiten mal olympischer ort nur
peking kann das für sich reklamieren
doch anders seit 2008 wirkt chinas
olympia ehrgeiz heute nicht mehr als
aufbruch sondern als weltmacht streben
und die begeisterung der menschen als
diktiert stefanie schöneborn berichtet
wie bilder verführen können sich einer
illusion hinzugeben
china schwärmte weil es zum ersten mal
die olympischen spiele austragen durfte
das war 2008 und die welt hofft dass
china sich öffnen würde
china war damals noch sehr viel mehr
eine aufsteigende großmacht es war ein
land was sich auch generell geöffnet hat
auf das man neugierig war was durchaus
auch neugierig war auf die
weltgemeinschaft
2008 war es in ping noch einer von
vielen möglichen kandidaten für die
parteiführung er wird nur vier jahre
später der neue präsident china sein und
heute ist china shipping das zentrum des
chinesischen volkes vielleicht der
mächtigste mann der welt
wird diese spiele benutzen um sich als
neue moralische instanz zu inszenieren
in peking beginnt morgen abend die
olympischen winterspiele
die welt blickt auf china und china ist
bereit
doch die welt blickt kritisch auf china
darüber können auch die bilder der
vielen glücklich drapierten fähnchen
schwenker nicht hinwegtäuschen und hieß
imping wird auch bilder mit putin
erzeugen wollen den trifft er morgen
vorab um einen schulterschluss der
beiden großmächte zu demonstrieren im
stadion wo die eröffnungsfeier
stattfindet werden sie mit einem
handverlesenen publikum auf halbleeren
rängen sitzen nicht nur wegen corona die
usa und viele europäische
regierungschefs trafen die chinesen mit
fernbleiben aber die freie welt spricht
nicht mit einer stimme aus angst vor
chinas wirtschaftsmacht
ich persönlich finde dass diese form des
diplomatischen boykott die null wirkung
hat china ist so selbstbewusst dass es
vor einem solchen boykott keine angst
hat der westen aber war nicht in der
lage eine bessere lösung zu finden
ich glaube die westliche gemeinschaft
hat es versäumt wirklich mit einer
geschlossenheit mit einer gemeinsamen
stimme gegenüber china zu sprechen in
zeiten wo china noch nicht so mächtig
und einflussreich war
[Applaus]
2008 freute sich die welt mit china und
hoffte insgeheim auf eine politische
annäherung wie bilder täuschen können
eine pompöse feier wie damals wird es
nicht mehr geben
20 22 haben viele vor allem angst vor
dem roten riesen
[Applaus]
unser korrespondent in china wird morgen
die eröffnungsfeier mit kommentieren ja
und wie wird das werden gigantismus wie
2008 wie wird sich china präsentieren
also wir hatten schon die gelegenheit
ein bisschen die proben der
eröffnungsfeier zu sehen und da ist
schon ein gewaltiger unterschied 2008
hatte man den eindruck so hat das eine
kollegin beschrieben das ist ein reiches
china das der ganzen welt zeigen will
was es erreicht hat wie viel geld es
auch gemacht hat wie wichtig es ist und
das kam dann halt mit diesem großen
nationalen patos ich glaube jetzt
erleben wir ein china
2022 band dieser feier die reduziert da
ist alles ist selbstverständlicher china
ist aus seiner sicht das zentrum der
welt ist wahrscheinlich aus seiner sicht
auch mindestens auf augenhöhe mit den
amerikanern um so präsentiert man sich
noch eine sehr interessante sache die
man auch feststellen wird es gibt viel
friedenstauben es gibt sehr viel bei
dieser show wo china sagt wir sind
eigentlich ein moralischer welt nation
und welten führer und wollen alles
zusammenführen und dass es dann auch ein
bisschen der etiketten ständen
etikettenschwindel die man kennen muss
weil natürlich die welten lage doch viel
viel schwieriger ist die hoffnung war ja
2008 wandel durch handel das war dieser
ansatz von dem alle sprachen ist er nun
gescheitert man hat den eindruck jetzt
wird handel getrieben aber china
bestimmt sein wandel selbst
absolut ist er gescheitert und ich
glaube keiner gibt sich im westen mehr
der illusion hin dass diese strategie
funktionieren kann es ist vielleicht
weniger das problem dass china seinen
wandel selber bestimmt die zeiten wo der
westen mit dem moralischen zeigefinger
quasi auf china zeigen konnte ist aus
chinesischer sicht völlig weg man wird
sich nicht mehr belehren lassen das
problem eigentlich ist das china
versucht über seine große
wirtschaftsmacht die das land hat eben
auch die meinungsbildung in europa auch
in deutschland zu steuern es wird immer
weniger china kritisiert aus
wirtschaftlichen interessen weil viele
deutsche firmen angst haben dass sie
dann von den chinesen sanktioniert
werden also das problem dieses thema mit
china ist nicht so sehr dass wir keine
freiheit in china haben sondern dass die
leute die jetzt vom fernseher sitzen die
zuschauer die jetzt uns zuschauern
wissen müssen wenn es um china geht da
geht es eben auch um ihre freiheit jetzt
neben deutsche regierungsvertreter nicht
teil der bundeskanzler nicht keine
minister einen förmlichen diplomatischen
boykott wie die usa oder kanada hat
deutschland aber nicht ausgerufen wird
das eigentlich registriert bei der
chinesischen führung schaut man da auf
die nuancen wer was macht
absolut ich würde sogar sagen dass die
chinesen glauben ist es ein erfolg jeder
diplomatie wie es so schön heißt der
schnittstellen diplomatie das eben
europa nicht geschafft hat eine
einheitliche meinung herzustellen es
gibt einige länder die sind mittlerweile
so abhängig dass china glaubt dass diese
länder eben nicht mehr souverän
entscheiden können was sie wollen
sondern auf das kommando aus peking
hören und so kommt eben diese etwas
diffus opposition das ist verschiedener
sehr sehr wichtig auch gerade was
deutschland angeht diese enge
wirtschaftsbeziehungen china ist das
wichtig dass hier kein boykott genannt
wurde da ausgesprochen wurde wie gesagt
das ist erfolg von chinesischer starke
und so wird das in peking auch gesehen
2008 kamen die regierungschefs noch in
scharen jetzt ist der westen im grunde
nicht mehr vertreten dafür kommt
wladimir putin und es wird morgen
wahrscheinlich bei der eröffnungsfeier
schon so ein symbolbild werden oder
ich glaube das ist das wichtigste
politische bild das diese
eröffnungsfeier produziert man muss ja
wissen eröffnungsfeier sind einerseits
ein sinnliches fest ein augenschmaus
aber es sind auch politische
veranstaltungen shipping präsentiert
sich da als der große führer seines
landes und wird die macht demonstrieren
und dieser schulterschluss mit putin der
ja ganz bewusst gewählt wird und die
tatsache dass alle länderchefs
regierungschef aus der freien welt eben
nicht da sind soll doch sehr deutlich
zeigen dass eben putting und chipping an
einer seite stehend gegen den freien
westen und dass beide der ansicht sind
dass eben gerade auch europa schwach ist
und beide glauben dass sie doch immer
mehr
linien nach verschieben können und mehr
oder weniger die geschichte auf ihrer
seite steht also es ist ein bild das
durchaus auch angst machen kann den
freien westen wir werden es sehen morgen
die eröffnungsfeier ab 12 uhr 10 im zdf
dann auch mit ulf röller herzlichen dank
für die erläuterung heute abend
wegen der zeitverschiebung haben wir das
gespräch am frühen abend aufgezeichnet
zu empfehlen ist die dokumentation von
ulf röller und stefanie schöneborn
chinas angriff auf die freiheit in der
zdf mediathek und das interview mit
chinas wohl bekanntesten dissidenten
railway später im heute journal update
wie umgehen mit china wie umgehen mit
russland der neue spd vorsitzende lars
klingbeil stellte heute in einem
interview ließ diese frage und forderte
eine überprüfung der deutschen
aussenpolitik wir haben sagte er bis
heute keinen überzeugenden umgang mit
autoritären staaten gefunden da ist mal
eine aufgabe auch für den spd kanzler
beschrieben wie unterschiedlich die
maßstäbe sind wenn es um freiheit und
werte geht zeigte sich am nachmittag als
moskau zum schlag gegen deutsche medien
in russland ausholte dem auslandssender
deutsche welle wurde ein sendeverbot
angekündigt die akkreditierungen der
journalisten entzogen eine politische
retourkutsche zu den hintergründen
kamera safari an
die deutsche welle darf in russland
nicht mehr senden das büro muss
schließen die journalisten verlieren
ihre arbeitserlaubnis das lässt das
russische außenministerium heute
offiziell verlauten
hintergrund ist das verbreitungsverbot
seines staatssenders russia today in
deutschland gestern der deutsche
journalisten verband ist empört ich
finde das erschreckend ich finde das
erstaunlich es waren ja
vergeltungsmaßnahmen angekündigt das ist
eine kriegs vokabel das muss man sich
vorstellen und das zeigt wie ernst der
russische staat das nimmt nur hier
werden äpfel mit birnen verglichen die
deutsche welle ist kein staatsrundfunk
russia today jedoch steht seit langem
für camel propaganda und desinformation
noch im januar hatte bundesaußenminister
in bernburg bei ihrem treffen mit ihrem
amtskollegen lawrow in moskau erklärt
dass in deutschland kein staats funk
erlaubt sein die deutsche medienaufsicht
hat gestern dann die verbreitung von
russia today verboten
das entscheidungsgremium der
medienanstalten ist zu der überzeugung
gelangt dass die rt productions gmbh mit
sitz in berlin an solchen eigenständigen
eigenverantwortlichen fernsehsender
betreibt und deswegen lizenz wichtig ist
eine solche fernseh lizenz liegt aber
uns nicht vor und deswegen waren wir von
amts wegen gehalten den sendebetrieb zu
untersagen jetzt also die reaktion
moskaus die deutsche welle der
unabhängige auslandssender der
bundesrepublik hat rechtliche schritte
gegen das verbot angekündigt auch die
spitzen von ard zdf und des
deutschlandradios protestieren heute wir
verurteilen die schließung der büros der
deutschen welle in russland hit freie
unabhängige berichterstattung radikal
eingeschränkt und politischen druck
auszuüben
das auswärtige amt sprach von einer
erneuten belastung der deutsch
russischen beziehungen
auch politiker in bund und ländern
reagieren die deutsche welle mit ihrem
sitz in bonn steht für unabhängigen
journalismus steht für den austausch der
kulturen und völker das ist ihr klarer
auftrag das vorgehen russlands gegen die
deutsche welle ist ein schwerer angriff
auf die pressefreiheit und inakzeptabel
das geht von der russischen seite
wahrscheinlich auch darum uns irgendwie
zu zeigen dass sie so hart sind aber ich
glaube so geht es nicht wir sehen sehr
deutlich dass sie freie presse in
russland unter druck egal ob sie
deutsche solar russisch die deutsch
russischen beziehungen
sie haben heute einen weiteren tiefpunkt
erreicht
nachfrage bei axel stein im zdf studio
moskau axel bisher wurde mit
konsequenzen gedroht
jetzt macht die russische führung
wirklich ernst mit sofortiger wirkung
konnte noch mehr
ja das ist schwer zu sagen ob da noch
mehr kommt wir erwarten morgen ein
briefing im außenministerium hier in
moskau möglicherweise kommt da noch mehr
aber ganz sicher ist morgen früh um 9
uhr ortszeit hier erlischt die
sendelizenz der deutschen welle die
kolleginnen und kollegen müssen ihre
akkreditierungen zurückgeben dürfen dann
nicht mehr journalistisch arbeiten in
der russischen föderation
das ist ein schwerer schlag eine schwere
politische entscheidung schwerwiegende
politische entscheidung gegen deutsche
medienvertreterinnen und medienvertreter
und leider auch gegen die pressefreiheit
in russland wie groß ist der der
politische flurschaden aus ministerien
berbalk war ja gerade erst in moskau ein
termin der jedenfalls bei diesem thema
die fronten ja sehr deutlich gemacht hat
ja die fronten waren absolut deutlich
aufs tapet hat das thema ja eine
kollegin von rt gebracht auf der
gemeinsamen pressekonferenz der
deutschen außenministerin und ihres
russischen amtskollegen
annalena baerbock sagte damals sie sehe
in deutschland keine beeinträchtigung
der arbeit von russischen
journalistinnen und journalisten sie
hätten zugang zu hochrangigen foren zum
beispiel der bundespressekonferenz sie
könnten frei arbeiten werden auf fast
jeder demo vor ort aber außenminister
lawrow auf merkte man schon an dass das
thema sehr in ihm geht und er sagte
er gehe davon aus nach wie vor das ist
hier auch das kontinuierliche narrativ
dass die bundesregierung einen wie er
sagte bezug zu den problemen rund um rt
habe und man werde eine antwort
formulieren was wir heute erlebt haben
ist vermutlich genau diese antwort danke
schön axel sturm nach moskau ja keine
entspannung auch in russland ukraine
konflikt im gegenteil damit beginnen die
nachrichten mit gundula gause ja trotz
intensiver diplomatischer bemühungen
verschärfen sich gegenseitige drohungen
moskau wirft der us-regierung vor zu
eskalieren und drohte maßnahmen an gegen
die von den usa angekündigte verlegung
von 2000 soldaten nach osteuropa in kiew
hat sich zugleich der türkische
präsident erdogan erneut als vermittler
zwischen russland und der ukraine
angeboten gegenüber präsident lenski
forderte er alle parteien zur
zurückhaltung und dialog auf
bei einem us militäreinsatz in
nordsyrien ist der anführer der
terrornetz al-kaida getötet worden
us-präsident beiden bestätigte
spezialeinheiten hätten all courage in
der provinz idlib aufgespürt während des
einsatzes habe sich der terrorist in die
luft gesprengt nach angaben syrischer
beobachter wurden bei der mehrstündigen
militäraktion 13 menschen getötet
darunter vier kinder
im streit um die praxis regeln für
nordirland ist der nordirische
regierungschef poul gewinn
zurückgetreten damit steht die
regionalregierung vor dem aus neue
unruhen werden befürchtet der
nordirische landwirtschaftsminister
hatte zuvor angeordnet lebensmittel aus
großbritannien nicht mehr zu
kontrollieren
das sei gesetzeswidrig kritisieren der
koalitionspartner irland und die eu
das robert koch institut fordert zur
erhöhung der korona impfquote mehr
aufklärung und info kampagnen für
menschen mit migrationsgeschichte nicht
das herkunftsland sei scheint so eine rk
ii studie sondern sprachkenntnisse und
kriterien wie bildung und einkommen
grundsätzlich sei die impfbereitschaft
unter zugewanderten hoch viele fühlten
sich aber wegen zb geringerer deutsch
kompetenzen benachteiligt
gut 74 prozent der bevölkerung sind
vollständig geimpft mindestens 53 6
prozent haben zusätzlich eine
auffrischungsimpfung erhalten die
ständige impfkommission hat nun eine
zweite booster impfung empfohlen für
risikogruppen ältere und beschäftigte in
medizinischen und pflegeeinrichtungen
die stiko empfiehlt zudem den einsatz
eines weiteren corona impfstoffes dass
us-aktien nowaks häufig als tot
impfstoff bezeichnet weil es keine
vermehrungsfähige viren enthält
männer die auf einen see schauen mit
diesem foto motiv wollten csu chef
markus söder und der damals noch
designierte cdu chef friedrich merz
schon anfang januar ihre neue harmonie
beschwören es gab eher spott über das
treffen am kirche bei dem mal der eine
dann der andere die richtung vorgeben
dürfte aber es war es der anfang heute
legten die beiden bei der klausur der
csu landesgruppe in berlin nach und wer
die letzten jahre dass kritik die
sticheleien die missgunst beobachtet
hatte die übrigens immer deutlich mehr
von bayern aus ging traute seinen ohren
nicht aus berlin matthias vetter
es ist die geschichte von zwei ganz
großen egos von rivalität und neuem
respekt der eine wirkt ausgesprochen
selbstbewusst der andere zurückgenommen
und ungewohnt kontrolliert
das friedrich merz auf einer
klausurtagung der csu auftritt ist an
sich nicht ungewöhnlich dass der neue
cdu-chef geradezu gönnerhaft dass
katastrophen war ja parkt irgendwie
schon die haben das gesamte jahr 2021
hinter uns gelassen das ist geschichte
darüber sprechen wir nicht mehr jetzt
geht es um die gegenwart und um die
zukunft und da werden sie von uns viel
höher freue mich darauf märz ist jetzt
der starke mann der union und die csu
versucht nicht klein neben dem neuen cdu
vorsitzenden zu wirken der gerade mit 95
prozent gewählt wurde ein ergebnis dass
du da noch nie erreicht hat
gratulation auch zur im
erneuerungsprozess mit den klaren
ergebnissen man merkte kraft schwung
wunsch zur veränderung besinnung auf
alte tugend und entdeckung von neuen
stärken ich glaube das ist es was uns
verbindet doch auch wenn sie so tun die
geschlossenheit hat grenzen gerade beim
thema ukraine gab es den letzten tagen
echte meinungsverschiedenheiten bis soda
einlenkt noch vor zwei wochen pünktlich
zum cdu parteitag hatte söder per
zeitungsinterview waffenlieferungen für
die ukraine und sanktionen gegen
russland ausgeschlossen heute morgen die
überraschende kehrtwende
alles wird auf den tisch ist ja klar ist
hängt davon ab was am ende passiert auch
die csu-landesgruppe drängte söder und
alexander dobrindt lässt seinen
parteichef durch die gast auswahl des
vormittags erkennen was er denkt
wolfgang ischinger chef der
sicherheitskonferenz ist ein klarer
transatlantiker fest an der seite der
verbündeten mit einer botschaft nicht
nur an die regierung es ist eine
wichtige erfahrung aus der deutschen
geschichte des letzten jahrhunderts
sondern auch dieses beginn des
jahrhunderts dass es nicht gut ist wird
deutschland sonder wege beschreitet
kritik aus der fraktion ja sogar aus der
eigenen landesgruppe söder will am ende
nicht als putin versteher gelten märz
gibt sich zufrieden vielleicht haben wir
da etwas unterschiedliche nuancen aber
im ergebnis ganz einheitliche auffassung
stattdessen volle attacke auf den
bundeskanzler für deutschland und für
europa und auch für die politische
friedensordnung dieses kontinents ist
das ein desaster dass der bundeskanzler
der bundesrepublik deutschland im
augenblick offensichtlich gelähmt und
blockiert ist die csu sucht ihre rolle
so wie corona bedingt immer neue klose
hatte dem berliner industrie hinterhof
fehlt jedenfalls noch der traditionelle
charme von alpen panorama schnee und
kloster
welche konsequenz zieht die katholische
kirche aus dem missbrauchskandal
viele gläubige ziehen in diesen tagen
diese konsequenz austritt die die an
erneuerung glauben wünschen sich
tiefgreifende reformen solche die an das
machtgefüge der kirche gehen und damit
die systemischen ursachen für missbrauch
und täterschutz beseitigen dem
sogenannten synodalen also gemeinsamen
weg von geistlichen und laien wir dabei
viel bedeutung zugemessen seit heute
tagt in frankfurt die dritte
vollversammlung die vielleicht letzte
chance für die katholische kirche zur
erneuerung die geräte bleibt skeptisch
gleich wird moderatorin julia reck mit
ihrem gast zum thema gender ansprechen
seit 2017 arbeitet die journalistin für
den katholischen sender zusammen mit 30
anderen sie wissen was gläubige bewegt
gerade jetzt ist viel wut und
enttäuschung über eine kirche die in den
augen vieler versagt hat es gibt jetzt
ans eingemachte
es ist eine kernschmelze die wir erleben
die menschen an der basis sind es
irgendwie leid sie wollen endlich taten
sehen
mindestens 497 opfer zählt das gutachten
der diözese münchen und freising
vermutlich sind es noch viel mehr es
sind zahlen die auch die hörer vom
domradio erschüttern denn es geht um
verbrechen gegen kinder ich fürchte wir
sehen die kirche gerade in sich
zusammenbrechen schreibt zum beispiel
eine hörerin
die katholische kirche steht immer
stärker unter druck rufe nach
veränderungen und reformen werden lauter
das kommt auch bei den verantwortlichen
an zum beispiel die abschaffung des
pflichtzölibats
münchen hat die situation noch mal
ernster gemacht als sie es längst schon
ist es zeigt und macht deutlich
in der frage der verbrechen der
sexuellen gewalt an kindern und
jugendlichen in der katholischen kirche
und des umgangs der verantwortlichen
damit haben alle
gefehlt
das spiegelt sich in den zahlen der
kirchenaustritte wieder im schnitt
verlassen pro jahr etwa 200.000 gläubige
die katholische kirche noch tut dies der
kirche finanziell nicht wie
2020 nahm sie über sechs milliarden euro
an kirchensteuer ein auch der staat
subventioniert die
religionsgemeinschaften pro jahr
bekommen beide großen kirchen zusammen
rund 550 millionen euro
auch wenn am ende eine mehrheit der
bischöfe für reformen ist sie würden
dennoch an grenzen stoßen und das liegt
im selbstverständnis der katholischen
kirche die sich jetzt geschenk jesus
christus sieht und in der veränderungen
nicht vorgesehen sind
solange diese struktur nicht verändert
wird und sie gilt als unveränderlich
stoßen alle forderungen nach
demokratisierung oder eben
gewaltenteilung und kontrolle an besagte
gläserne decke
das thema missbrauch zeigt die kirche
ist mit der aufarbeitung überfordert
hier ist der staat gefragt auch bischof
bätzing spricht heute von einem beben
und fordert reformen doch schon längst
trauen viele gläubige genau das ihrer
kirche nicht mehr zu wie es scheint zu
recht
mit spannung wurde heute auf die
zinsentscheidung der ezb geschaut die
nachricht ist gundula es gibt keine und
genau das ist das thema an den
finanzmärkten die ausbleibende zinswende
im euroraum trotz der weiter anziehenden
inflation belässt die europäische
zentralbank das zinsniveau auf dem
rekordtief von 0 valerie viele anleger
und experten sind irritiert warum hält
die ezb derart an ihrem kurs fest
tatsächlich ist die ezb in einer
schwierigen lage sie hat es nicht mit
einem land zu tun sondern mit den
befindlichkeiten von ganz vielen
unterschiedlichen staaten einige davon
hoch verschuldet eine schnelle
zinserhöhung für sie wäre oder könnte
zumindest ein problem sein denn
schuldenmachen würde teurer eine politik
für alle ist schwierig das sieht man
auch an der inflation in deutschland und
belgien liegt die teuerung bei
geschätzten 5 bzw 8 prozent in
frankreich hingegen deutlich niedriger
nun bleibt also erstmal alles beim alten
ein bisschen aber hat sich die ezb doch
bewegt immerhin hat sie eingestanden
dass sich die inflation hartnäckige hält
als erwartet höhere zinsen sind nun auch
hier dieses jahr nicht mehr
ausgeschlossen eine sorge die die börse
umtreibt nach der ezb-sitzung fällt der
dax kräftig heute war da noch der
facebook schock der mutterkonzern meter
liegt schwache geschäftszahlen vor
manche sie in facebook schon auf dem
absteigenden ast bei meta aktien löst
die nachricht einen crash aus - 27
prozent in absoluten zahlen heißt das
gut 200 milliarden dollar börsenwert
verpufft in wenigen minuten facebook
schreibt börsengeschichte noch nie
verlor ein unternehmen am aktienmarkt in
absoluten zahlen so viel geld an einem
tag valerie haller vielen dank
dieter mann einer der beliebtesten
schauspieler der ddr ist im alter von 80
jahren gestorben sein jahrzehntelanges
wirken auch als intendant des deutschen
theaters in berlin sowie in film und
fernsehen beschrieb er in seiner
autobiografie schöne vorstellung als
denken mitfühlen mitteilen
im rheinland pfälzischen kusel wurde am
abend der getöteten polizeianwärterin
und ihres kollegen gedacht die junge
frau und der 29 jährige
polizeioberkommissar waren am
montagmorgen bei einer verkehrskontrolle
getötet worden bei einem ökumenischen
gottesdienste wurde für die opfer
gebetet mit angehörigen und freunden
getrauert die polizei in rheinland pfalz
und dem saarland
für morgen 10 uhr zu einer bundesweiten
schweigeminute aufgerufen
im wattenmeer der nordsee nur wenige
kilometer vor der insel wangerooge ist
ein container schiff auf grund gelaufen
die fast 400 meter lange mumbai maersk
war auf dem weg von rotterdam nach
bremerhaven aus noch ungeklärter ursache
hatte sich das schiff beim ansteuern der
wesermündung festgefahren ein erster
versuch den frachter in tieferes
fahrwasser zu bringen scheiterte in der
kommenden nacht soll es mit stärkeren
schleppern und der flut gelingen
donnerstagabend wir geben sie jetzt
direkt weiter an maybrit illner
interessante gäste zum thema russland
ukraine konflikt um 0.30 meldet sich
hier christopher wehrmann mit unserem
heute-journal update schön amt noch bis
morgen
[Musik]
sogenannte und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter es war heute in den nachrichten
die klimabedingten extremwetter schäden
haben in den letzten 40 jahren
zugenommen in deutschland das waren die
höchsten europaweit und es verwundert
kaum die temperatur und global steigen
ja immer weiter an und das feiert die
extreme wetterereignisse ansehen es hier
in rot dargestellt der bereich wo die
temperaturen angestiegen sind ja und die
wärme die setzt sich weiter fort wir
bekommen aus dem südwesten warme luft ab
und so steigen die werte teilweise auf
zweistellige temperaturen die kaltluft
hier die sorgt vorübergehend für eine
abkühlung aber so richtig eisig kalt wie
es für februar üblich wäre wird es auch
nicht wir schauen denn die nachteil gibt
es einige schauer die verlagern sich
nach nordosten hin und die temperaturen
sinken an den alpen auf minus drei grad
ganz im westen auf plus 7 grad morgen
liegt die kaltfront dann im nordwesten
schon teils mit schweren sturmböen und
schauern das ganze verlagert sich
allmählich nach juneau zum nachmittag
liegt die kaltfront quer über
deutschland und auch mit gewittern
müssen wir rechnen schwere sturmböen
sind dann mit dabei das ganze verlagert
sich dann richtung abends weiter nach
südosten temperaturen dazu erreichen
höchstwerte von fünf gerade im osten
deutschlands 10 grad im westen sowie im
südwesten ja an einem samstag gibt es
einzelne schauer in den bergen durch
auch einige schneeflocken im süden viel
sonne bei drei bis neun grad und am
sonntag erreicht uns der nächste
kräftige sturm damit ein schöner abend